[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle envie de lecture aujourd'hui
nos chers invités laurent et stéphanie
donc bonjour qu'est ce que vous nous
avez apporté une sélection de beaux
livres
tout à fait une fois n'est pas coutume
on a parlé de beaux livres oui ça change
un peu
voilà alors on commence tout de suite
par les années vogue donc du photographe
robert doisneau qui a donc photographié
si j'ai bien compris la vie parisienne
mondaine et artistique quoi des années
cinq ans 57 sél effectivement pendant
une dizaine d'années il a collaboré avec
le magazine vogue et en exclusivité pour
harry c'est une exclusivité pour va tout
à fait ou comme vous dites voilà il a
photographié les scènes parisiennes de
l'époque alors à la fois monde n est
effectivement culturel
ouais donc fait penser à un doigt nos qu
on ait pu enfin pas habitués à voir un
doisneau outre le bizet de moins bien
c'est quand même les trois voilà ça
quand même les poulbots de paris le
fonds doit hausser le noir et blanc
c'est essentiellement parce que les
petites gens voilà le les voilà devant
le coeur de paris
rungis j'avais parlé des halles voilà
surtout les halles c'est les photos de
halle de doisneau son lancement un
génial et là en fait l'analyse et le
doisneau parce que c'est que du noir et
blanc on retrouve ça voilà dans brassens
voilà il est allé à l'opéra de paris
aussi pour lord et des représentations
du gie jeanmaire enfin voilà plein de
personnalité on a peut-être un petit peu
oublié ou qui sont week-end le temps a
passé
moi ya quelques photos qui vont vraiment
vraiment enthousiasmé ému comme on a une
photo de karen blixen moi je m'attendais
pas du tout à voir qu'un hibou stand xm
donc voila voila l'auteur entre autres
de pour ce qui est l'américain
orson welles montand et signoret
répétant une pièce d'anne où il part
d'oddo abbas aux caisses de la voilà
c'est ça et puis le le clou c'est
effectivement c'est ce côté un peu
mondain avec des photos à la fois
burlesque presque way original gréco
voilà elle est belle celle de green
arrow effectivement avec sa tenue noire
mais ces déchets ont déjà été publiées
alors sont des clichés qu'il y avait
quelques uns avaient été publiées à tous
il y avait une grande exposition en 2012
pour commémorer le décès à la naissance
de douane au pardon en 2012 il y en
avait une très très belle expo à
beaubourg enfin au centre pompidou il y
en avait eu quelques-unes d'accord mais
là c'est vraiment ça regroupe vraiment
l'ensemble de ce qu'il a fait après pour
exhaler des photos de l'état des bugs
tout à fait avec colom quelques-unes nom
du don culturelle est une de sartre nine
de cocteau certaines voilà de 22 oui et
c'est effectivement assez déroutante
voire doisneau dans cette forme là mais
lui-même disait que finalement ces
photos-là l'avait aidé aussi un avoir de
la patience il faut être extrêmement
patient pour être photographe est finie
finalement les photos de rue qu'il
prenait
ouais y en a eu beaucoup effectivement
c'est sur le vif mais quand même il faut
attendre et c'est justement ces
photos-là de mode de voilà de mondanités
ça lui avait appris justement être
encore plus pas si ce n'était pas des
photos instantanées les photos de
fausses voilà ce qui n'était pas du tout
le même procédé effectivement un très
très beau livre est une très belle
édition des coups de feu
superbe vraiment vraiment ça vaut
vraiment le coup et l'ex profite bien
sûr la déco bonne ou d'une autre façon
former la personne à mi course et fanny
on va enchaîner alors du coup avec rod
ans dont c'est un peu le mentionner un
bonheur exactement avec l'événement sion
ton celtes et au grand palais est
actuellement qui a juste de débuter que
finir à fin juillet enfin la principale
alors moi j'avais je voulais présenter
deux ouvrages donc le premier c'est un
récit sur l'accompagnement de rodin
c'est se mettre à côté de lui
l'accompagner sur sa création sur sa
liberté
donc c'est parce qu'on voit
habituellement face qu'on étudie ou
qu'on dit sur europe 1 c'est vraiment
quelque chose
une mise à côté et un accueil
accompagnement dans sa création oui tout
à fait vrai accompagnement chez fayard
hambourg et 6 4 et sinon le musée rodin
a publié donc un ouvrage un très bel
ouvrage
donc ouais c'est le conservateur du
musée rodin qui est sorti cet ouvrage
n'a donc voilà c'est tout les rafales
masson édité chez flammarion donc là
c'est vraiment il ya des archives
il ya des leurs clichés qui ne sont pas
qu'ils aient fait inédit on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir en fait donc les
oeuvres les sculptures on les connaît
mais là c'est ce sont des prises de vue
un peu aussi différente de ce qu'on voit
habituellement
et donc voilà on voit des manuscrits une
très belle mise en page
donc c'est vraiment tout un ensemble sur
redin son oeuvre et voilà sur une vision
aussi un peu
différente de ce qu'on peut voir
actuelle je sais j'ai vu dans un mois il
ya un film qui va sortir la vague doyon
mais cinéma par jacques doillon ou c'est
vincent vincent lindon qui va jouer
auguste rodin d'accord tu sais pas si
vous avez vu les bandes annonces et ce
très beau et il ya également est
effectivement un film documentaire que
je suggère à vivement de voir en replay
ou en dvd produit par arte qui s'appelle
divino inferno on voit ici le visuel
réalisé par bruno aveillan artistes
plasticiens et c'est un très beau film
où les sculptures prennent 10 qui mêle
danse poésie littérature
ils sont animés de sang qui est en fait
c'est oui il a il a avec des danseurs il
ya un artiste contemporain qui s'évade
mircea cantor qui fut une performance au
musée rodin des danseuses qui s'anime et
bruno aveillan film de l'esthétique
visuelle assez magnifique pour filmer
les corps en mouvement et voilà je vous
conseille de le voir s est inspiré du
travail de création de rodin sur la
porte de l'enfer où il essaie tant bien
que mal inspiré de la divine comédie de
dante voilà suggère également d'y jeter
un oeil c'est sur arte l'art c'est
effectivement mais ça a été diffusée
puiser le 2 avril que l'on se le voir en
replay ou je prends un dvd en dvd est
également d'accord
bonne idée on enchaîne avec pizarro
camille pissarro enfin avec sa tasse et
le sait le catalogue des blessures au
deuxième et envoie l'un jusqu'au mois de
juillet je me souviens bien et tout à
fait qu'elle est et qui est en cours en
quête on court tout voilà qui a commencé
en février
oui bah pizarro c'est un peu le mal
connu un petit peu je dirais de pour
l'impressionnisme et pourrait nous
revoilà un sac photo m à la fois le
premier le maître tout à fait ça aurait
fait ça et alors il est né aux îles
vierges pizarro moi je ne savais pas en
fait
et on comprend du coup la lumière qui a
effectivement toujours illuminer ses
tableaux parce que la lumière qui tombe
bien ils reprennent la mer est encore
plus sur une île une voix particulière
il a vécu aussi au venezuela magalas et
puis après il a étudié effectivement
beaux-arts à paris
il a beaucoup travaillé effectivement en
extérieur avec les séries comme on l a
fait pour voir la cathédrale de rouen a
toujours peint deux jours le le même
lieu le même paysage à toutes les heures
de la journée pour voir justement les
différences de lumière qu'il ya donc lui
c'est beaucoup il a beaucoup fait ça il
ya effectivement quelques exemples il
est également aussi aller un roman et
c'est une façon aussi de découvrir voilà
pizarro l'aurait découvrir moi c'est un
artiste que j'aime beaucoup
effectivement l'heure ce sont des scènes
de ville des scènes effectivement on
suit les saisonnalité on suit petites
gens voilà là au milieu des champs au
milieu des fleurs je suis à mon belle
expo est très très belle exposition au
musée d'orsay re sais plus si c'est en
2005 en 2006 c'était cézanne et surtout
très proches très proches ils ont bon
goût l'oreiller ensemble effectivement
ils ont participé les ans tous les deux
tous les salon des refusés notamment le
premier 1 voilà c'est ça c'est comme ça
qu'ils ont été connus et reconnus et ont
été lancés énormément énormément
énormément critiqué commence voilà donc
c'est une façon de le découvrir ou de
houle redécouvrir surtout là avec le
printemps qui arrivent sont encore plus
avant d'aller c'est très très chaud en
plein désert avant de s'élancer des
maréchaux et effectivement c'est un
petit musée que dans un hôtel
particulier avec un joli jardin alors
c'est vraiment oui là il faut y aller
c'est rare et très beau musée
c'est là d'ailleurs vous élire celui de
monet impression soleil levant si je me
souviens bien voilà c'est un joli musée
il n'y a peut-être pas forcément ça
c'est pas musée d'orsay
oui ça là mais c'est du coup une des
dépositions un peu intimiste et l'album
enfin le met très beaux ouvrages webo
suis donc chronologiquement
effectivement son travail de prévoit
également aussi l'évolution les
inspirations
c'est un livre bilingue on à la fois
français est d'accord pour améliorer son
anglais
voilà c'est effectivement dans un
ouvrage que je trouve qui à la fois
complète l'exposition ou apport si on
n'a pas si on n'a pas l'occasion à
l'expédition importe fictivement quelque
chose peut lui rendre hommage à pizarro
l'art et bien beaucoup
stéphanie et on continue avec vous il me
semble je crois moi pour ce dernier
ouvrage qui est le peuple des forêts
l'histoire de l'europe sauvage depuis
vingt mille ans voilà il me semble que
c'est le film le livre référence du
fouet les saisons tout à fait l'algérie
à s'acquitter de sortie à la à l'automne
à l'automne 2016 oui il y a eu ensuite
une
des épisodes télévisés enfin télévision
vous pouvez voir effectivement le film
par épisode
c'est effectivement le rapport entre
l'homme et la nature depuis donc voilà
comment l'homme finalement a petit à
petit pris place et en une emprise sur
la nature et sur le monde animalier
métrologie et comment aujourd'hui
finalement on aimerait un peu rien versé
le temps et essayer de remettre un petit
peu plus de place justement redonner un
petit peu plus de place à ce monde un
petit peu disparu faire beaucoup disparu
et d'autres y voient là non non pas du
tout non non c'est pas du tout
nostalgique parce que effectivement on
avance on avance quoi donc voilà il ya
juste d'essayer de vivre de façon un peu
plus intelligente encore donc à un
moment donné effectivement l'animal
était plus présent l'homme a pris petit
à petit effectivement le pas bien mais
naturellement enfin le cours de
l'histoire
l'évolution de l'homme a fait que et
puis petit à petit aussi il ya eu
peut-être ou peut-être trop je sais pas
une sur développement de on a rasé
plusieurs campagnes aux forêts pour
agriculture à outrance peut-être que
voilà qui a aussi détruit beaucoup de
choses mais finalement l' équilibre ci
n'est plus l'un et on le voit aussi dans
tout le discours qui a quand même
aujourd'hui fin juin sans être écolo ils
font sans être voilà il ya un besoin d'
équilibre entre nature et aux mains sur
dabo - raoult à forest bison ou la
maison c'est sûr que voilà et donc du
coup on a peut-être besoin encore faim
encore peut-être plus aujourd'hui de
retrouver un certain équilibre
mais on voit un d'ailleurs dans les
villes vers la la
très souvent quand les fans et toi sont
redeviennent vert mais il ya des cas les
abeilles voilà son étoile et les
meilleurs tout à fait ça donc il ya des
ya de plus en plus de café au berry si
oui ou non il ya un café où on voit des
parcelles tout autour c'est en fait la
queue dès que des parcelles de virgin
etc
desjardins way s'est départi voilà le
végétal de wallace et safran sans plus
new york même avec new york tout
simplement quoi donc c'est vrai qu'il ya
peut-être un besoin de nature ou du
moins de décès de revivre une
intelligence et en 1 qu'il y ait même
pour les avancées même pour les hommes
s'arrêtent pour l'écosystème d'accord
voilà donc et puis les photos sont
absolument extraordinaires rien pour ça
en fait les photos avant le tout à fait
merci beaucoup pour cette proposition
merci à tous les justes c'était pour
emmener les gens vers les musées aussi
voilà on voulait faire c'est la
sensation la focus parce que y'a voilà
il ya toute une vie qui est super
intéressante qui existe dans les musées
et qu'il faut se déplacer dans les
musées voilà le mois qui arrive vous
voulez avoir le mois de la photo là
profitez-en sans fil des ans les mains
partout et simplement génial merci à ses
obligés de vous de vous couper à très
bientôt on continuera cette digression
la prochaine fois merci à vous on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle en
lecture
[Musique]